I want to welcome everybody to our
regular Newberry kalokhe Newberry
Library colloquium and this week we have
a special treat actually as many of you
know Elliott born has lectured at the
Newberry before on mother jones at the
beginning of this project in the middle
of this project and now that he has
finished the project we are actually
going to see the fruits of his labors
much of which took place here to do very
some of you know Elliot through his
earlier work his first book was the
manly heart bare-knuckle prize fighting
in America one of the very early books
to start talking about manhood and
gender at a time when most people
assumed that gender meant women's
history he's also been the editor of
Muhammad Ali the People's Champ
selection from agafia selections from
mcguffey's readers a source book in
American history a three-volume
encyclopedia of American social history
and a brief history of American sports
and I'm always struck when someone
titles something a brief history because
half the time is brief and half the time
it's not brief and those of you who have
seen Mother Jones know that this effort
by Elliot is in fact not very brief
which i think is good for all of us in
terms of the amount of enjoyment that we
can get from the book Mother Jones the
most dangerous woman in America has been
published this year by filling Wang and
I encourage everybody to go out to
purchase a copy le can I have a copy to
hold up for everybody here
this is the book it is in the Newberry
library bookstore and also obviously
available in bookstores all around the
city and elsewhere Elliott received his
PhD from Yale University and has taught
at University of Alabama Miami
University and is now a professor of
history at Purdue University he's
received a variety of prestigious
fellowships Guggenheim's and things like
that but of course the most important
fellowship that he's received is at the
Newberry Library something that I
welcome Elliott once again
well it is it really is a pleasure to be
here the Newberry is my intellectual
home I don't know if there is a
microphone for the room as I was saying
the Newberry Library has been my
intellectual home for several years now
it's here that I come to do research and
to and to write and it's really been a
wonderful place to work and I think
finally I've produced something too - I
don't know about justifying all that
time but this book is finally done and
I'm pleased with that and I wanted to
share with you a little bit today what
Mother Jones is about um people sort of
know the name Mother Jones but they
don't know much about her they know
there's a magazine named after her but
really there's just kind of a an empty
image in some ways but she was a real
person and a very important one one of
the most famous women in all of America
I think between 1900 and 1930 I think
it's very I think there's no doubt about
that as a matter of fact and yet we've
really lost touch with her today I think
to understand her you have to know
something about the context of the times
it's only when you have some brief
context in which she lived that you get
a sense of the importance of her work
and what she was about I'm gonna show
some slides and read some passages and
talk about her talk about how others
talked about her spoke of her and then
try to try to talk a little bit about
her significance so let's let's do that
focus this is this focusing I'm not sure
it is but someone that
mmm failure from the beginning thanks
very much
that's a steel mill that's the guy
that's actually a homestead Pennsylvania
the steel works that Andrew Carnegie
built that eventually became part of a
part of a small part of the United
States steel after the turn of the
century the signals for us this mill
that employs thousands of people signals
what labor had become for many many
Americans by the turn of the century
labor in mills in mines men and women
both who are employees employees for
life still they're skilled laborers of
course but many many people many of them
immigrants many of them
african-americans from the South
increasing numbers working in mass
trades in in the basic industries the
basic industries that are developing
well for example coal these men are coal
miners if you think about coal around
1910 or so something like three-quarters
of a million men going to the earth and
mined coal American men coal is the
fundamental fuel to build industrial
America coal is what you use to make
steel what's used as a fuel in that
plant we just saw coal build steel
i-beams that build the skyscrapers in
Chicago coal becomes the rails that are
the the rare that are that are that
connect the railroads from city to city
and to ports the the Illinois Central
for example three-quarters of a million
men mining coal going into the earth
making something like 250 to 300 dollars
a year as coal miners right here in the
Middle West as far east as West Virginia
as far west as Colorado but especially
here in the Middle West
all of these coal miners bringing up
this precious rock that burns to fuel
the industrial economy and to create
fortunes for others Labor's also in many
cases about families as part of the
garment trade an entire family including
women and children very often working in
the home not in the most wholesome
conditions often ten twelve fourteen
hours
des and those people working because
that's what you need to produce enough
money for a family to live and again
very often immigrants very often in
cities like Chicago New York City and so
on and that's that's in a very very
brief nutshell the nature of where
American labor has gone right where does
that leave us with Mother Jones well we
can start with her funeral start in 1930
when she dies this and you see if that's
me focus there it's a little better 1930
when she died I think the best sentence
in the book is Mother Jones was 93 when
she celebrated her 100th birthday I like
that sense very much she claimed to have
been born in 1918 30 uh and actually in
actuality she was born in 1837 but here
she is in December of 1930 about to be
buried in mana all of Illinois at the
very end of her life and at her funeral
ceremonies father John McGuire who
worked with Mother Jones in the 1919
steel strike gave the eulogy he said my
dear friends today in gorgeous mahogany
furnished and carefully got it carted
offices in distant capitals wealthy mine
owners and capitalists are breathing
sighs of relief today upon the plains of
Illinois the hillsides and valleys of
Pennsylvania and West Virginia in
California Colorado and British Columbia
strongmen and toil war and women are
weeping tears of bitter grief the
reasons are the same Mother Jones is
dead as we contrasts men of great wealth
happy that she's gone and wait workers
Labor's mourning her passing and as it
turns out tens of thousands of people
came to her funeral in this tiny town of
Mount Olive Illinois where the United
Mine Workers owned the only Union owned
cemetery in America tens of thousands of
people came onto railroad cars and
someone came to Mount Olive to pay their
last respects to mother Jones when she
when she passed away well
who was this woman and that was really
part of the process of writing this book
it's not as easy it's not as easy as it
seems it doesn't appear she doesn't
appear to you quite as readily there's
an autobiography that she wrote in 1925
trouble with the autobiography as it has
many inaccuracies in it like the fact
that she was born in 1830 which she
wasn't the fact that she came with her
family five years later to America and
her family were Irish freedom fighters
Irish rebels that her father was
arrested in Ireland or left Ireland just
before arrest none of that seems to be
true they left Ireland they left the
County Cork but they left during the
famine and she never speaks of that so
there's this mystery about her what
she's doing when she tells those stories
about her family in Ireland is in
creating this great a lineage for
herself this lineage of rebellion of
revolution Upton Sinclair who wrote the
great muckraking book that the jungle
about the packing industry describe
Mother Jones once he said there broke
out a storm of applause which swelled
into a tumult as the little woman came
forward on the platform
she was wrinkled and old dressed in
black looking like somebody's
grandmother she wasn't Ruth the
grandmother of hundreds of thousands of
miners Sinclair went on describing her
hearing her speak you discovered the
secret of her influence over these
polyglot hordes she had force she had
whipped above all she had the fire of
indignation
she was the walking wrath of God and
Sinclair went on to describe how she
worked a crowd what she did she would
tell endless stories about her
adventures above strikes she had led and
speeches she had made about interviews
with presidents and governors and
captains of industry about jails and
convict camps all over the country she'd
roamed and wherever she went the the
flame of protest had leapt up in the
hearts of men
her story was a veritable Odyssey of
revolt so he's describing this woman and
here she is about to appear in Carnegie
Hall in New York City shortly after the
great strike ended in West Virginia in
1913 about to about to appear in in
Carnegie Hall and Sinclair is describing
her he says the walking wrath of
this very common description this anger
that she has that she communicates to
her audience and she is with them always
she is with him there's this sense in
all of the descriptions of her of just
how close she is to those whom she whom
she writes about um whom she speaks to
all of those who write about her another
former miner a official in the United
Mine Workers John Brophy describes the
first time he saw Mother Jones this goes
back to the late 19th century when
Brophy was still a minor in the
anthracite mines she came into the mine
one day and talked to us in our
workplace in the vernacular of the mines
how she got in I don't know probably
just walked in and defied anyone to stop
her when I first knew her she was in her
late middle age a woman of medium height
very sturdily built but not fat she
dressed conventionally it was not at all
unusual in appearance she would take a
drink with the boys and spoke their
idiom including some pretty rough
language when she was talking about the
bosses this might have been considered a
little fast in ordinary women but the
miners knew and respected her they might
think her a little odd perhaps it wasn't
all kind of work for a woman in those
days but they knew she was a good soul
and a friend of those who most lacked
friends this again is a common theme a
constant theme she is a friend of those
who lacked friends she puts her life on
the line she gets arrested with with the
miners she goes to prison she spends her
time in their cabins she is of them she
is one of them it's one of the one of
the techniques of organizing that she
uses if you're starting to get a picture
this is someone who is organizing across
the country coal miners especially but
not only coal miners steel workers women
who work in bottling plants of garment
workers in Chicago and other cities
trolley car workers across America she
organizes across America from about the
let well from the late 1890s her health
breaks down sometime in the early 1920s
and in those years she is in her 60s 70s
and 80s going up the hills in West
Virginia to mine camps rough mine camps
where people don't come out alive
sometimes and in Colorado and as late as
1919 in the steel strike the great
violent steel strike here on the the
southern shore of Lake Michigan and in
western Pennsylvania that's where she
was and all
out there and always as the reports are
always with her people these mine
families are in a camp called the Forbes
camp in Colorado in 1914 they're living
in tents they're living in tents because
they've been thrown out of their homes
they've been thrown out of their homes
because the homes they rented were owned
by the mine companies when they joined
the Union and went on strike they were
kicked out of their homes hundreds
thousands of families living like this
and Mother Jones was helping to organize
these organize these people when she
when she spoke to uh miners men
especially men like like these hair
miners they're young men she would
berate them that's one of her techniques
she wouldn't just it wasn't just
encouragement she would berate them you
have allowed a few men to boss you she
said you should just starve you to abuse
your women and children to deny you
education to make pans of you lower and
less free than the Negroes before the
Civil War what is the matter with you
are you afraid do you fear your pitiful
little bosses I can't believe it
I can't believe you're so cowardly and I
tell you this if you are you're not fit
to have women live with you constantly
this appeal to their manhood you can't
be real you you men are afraid little
old me seventy years old a little old
woman she said once with a hatpin
and I scared the bosses and you big
strong and I'm afraid it's part of her
technique that's berating them um
this is another image of a Colorado of
the great strike in Colorado in 1914 and
the image should tell you something
if you look at these faces we think of
mining especially in West Virginia
Kentucky Colorado we think of
Mountaineers native-born American
pioneers and so on these are immigrants
and many many of the in some cases a
majority of the miners and mine families
were immigrants african-americans in
pretty large numbers in West Virginia by
1912 1913 Mexican Italian Slovak in
Colorado and West Virginia
a very large proportion of them she
organized not just men she organized
women also white black immigrant she
said to women and wives of the miners in
this case every woman should arise and
stand shoulder-to-shoulder as the women
of the old Romans did 2,000 years ago
when they marched barefooted through the
desert to carry the message of hope to
their sister women and their brothers
that's the type of woman that has seen
the jail and the scaffold and has stood
side-by-side with her brother working on
the battlefields urging him to keep on
in this desperate struggle until victory
is ours the jail and the scaffold and
again when she said words like that she
meant it she was in prison
very often in horrible conditions and
she um some ones even courted this is
the scaffold I won't talk about this
today but there is in some ways a real
death wish I think in Mother Jones
that's maybe stating it a little
strongly but she really courts dangers
in room in amazing ways so the miners
and other workers and women wives of
workers women who work themselves and
children to these are breaker boys and
the mines breaker boys stood at the
chute as coal came up came up the chute
and picked slate from the coal itself
stuck their hands and had their hand
many of them had their hands destroyed
their bodies really crippled by that
position of bending over all day when
they didn't if they did get through that
job and most of they became miners
themselves they followed their fathers
into the mines mother jones organized
something called the Children's Crusade
in 1903 one of the early efforts against
child labour the United States didn't
actually have federal child labor
legislation that's stuck until the 1930s
but still this was an early effort to
get rid of child labor what's the use of
bringing a lot of children into the
world she said in a speech to make more
money for plutocrats while their little
lives are being drowned out in the mill
and the workshop the army I'm leading on
to New York this is her Children's
Crusade the army I'm leading on to New
York is composed of intelligent workmen
are causes a just one and we propose to
show that New York mill and millionaires
are grievances
so she dramatized social conditions with
her speeches with
Street Theatre with these sorts of
dramatic performances and the Children's
Crusade which is mixed it doesn't
succeed entirely still its headlines in
every major American newspaper for weeks
these children raped by cruel toil
beneath the iron wheels of greed are
starving in this country see the
over-the-top rhetoric very often but
she's a tremendous speaker everyone who
hears her talks about just how effective
she is would you have declared in the
height of its prosperity she writes this
to Theodore Roosevelt the president
United States there's a woman who knows
presidents these children raped by cruel
toil beneath the iron wheels of greed
are starving in this country which you
have declared is in the height of
prosperity we who know of these
sufferings have taken up their cause and
are now marching toward you in the hope
that your tender heart will counsel with
us to abolish this crime so she's gonna
march from Philadelphia with mill
children across New Jersey into New York
City on to Long Island to Sagamore Hill
where Theodore Roosevelt has his summer
home needless to say Theodore Roosevelt
is not home when she and the kids get
there he's busy somewhere else this is a
parade of her in Trinidad Colorado
during one of those during one of the
great strikes and again note the flag
it's very important one thing we often
lose sight of and then and this is
obviously this is nothing original with
me but the notion that the labor
movement and the left in America
generally very strongly associated
itself with patriotism and this is not
just a subterfuge they considered what
they were doing including the far left
in America they considered their ideas
their ideology their beliefs their
commitments that the organizations they
joined to be the embodiment of real
Americanism that the usurpers of the
real America were what Mother Jones and
that previous speech called the
plutocrats those who've built enormous
concentrations of wealth that are
denying most American men and women real
opportunity to better themselves
patriotism but also religion true
religion my mother Jones was a scoffer
at at conventional Christianity she
referred to all priests and ministers a
sky
pilots the guys will take you to the sky
to PI and PI buy and buy whatever um and
yet at the same time her speeches are
filled with religious imagery she's told
a group of miners once you men have come
over the mountains this is in West
Virginia twelve sixteen miles your
clothes are thin your shoes are out at
the toes your wives and little ones are
cold and hungry you've been robbed and
enslaved for years and now Billy Sunday
comes to tells you to be good and
patient and trusted justice what's silly
trash to tell two men whose goodness and
patience has cried out to a deaf world I
could see the tears in the eyes of those
poor fellows she describes this they
looked up into my face as much to say my
god mother have you brought us a ray of
hope someone screamed organized a
smother then they all began shouting
organize us organize us March over to
that dark short Church in the corner she
said and I will give you the ritual of
the Union all right so if you think
about this scene what she said I mean
organizes organizes it sounds like an
ecstatic religious service but it's a
union organizing meeting patriotism and
religion but defined in a fairly in a
fairly precise way um this again is in
Trinidad Colorado these images of her
this is a protest meeting when Mother
Jones was in Colorado in that for the
great 1913 1914 strike the largest
company was the Colorado fuel and iron
corporation owned by the Rockefeller
family and she was arrested and
imprisoned much of it in under terrible
circumstances I visited that where she
was arrested last summer actually um in
walls and burg Colorado the county seat
of of where Finnell County there were
protests like this people objecting to
her being arrested she of course always
said that she could create raise more
hell from prison than out then outside
of prison but this is the kind of impact
she had on people where her arrest would
bring thousands of letters into for
example if you go to the National
Archives you can see these thousands of
letters to the Department of Labor to
the White House protesting her arrest
one man wrote to the Secretary of Labor
a man named TJ Llewellyn I have carried
a gun three times in industrial wars in
this country and by the eternal if any
harm comes to the old mother I'm not too
old nor by the same token too cowardly
to carry it again
or another man from Ohio described her
when she was arrested this beautiful
hero of the labor movement has committed
no crime but is being slowly murdered
because she insisted on agitating and
educating the workers to realize their
true status in society
you get a sense of class in America that
Mother Jones is appealing to that's
really a very very powerful all right
I'm starting to get a sense of this
woman I hope who she is and again
there's a march in in Colorado she's
leading a parade of strikers to the
governor's office to petition for
redress now you have to understand when
she's these strikes for coal miners and
for others company housing as we talked
about company stores miners and many
other workers steel workers very similar
they can't just take their money and go
to the grocery store and buy groceries
first of all many of them aren't paid
with money they're paid with scrip
they're paid with little pieces of paper
that are io u--'s and they're only
redeemable in stores owned by the
companies that employ them selling goods
often at high prices often exorbitant
prices and the owners of the mines will
chase away anyone who tries to sell
otherwise sell to the miners peddlers
other store owners not allow them on
their property not allow them in the
area the mine companies and other
businesses hire private detectives
guards to enforce order to keep union
organizers out sometimes those guards
use guns and threats of violence and
more than threats of violence Mother
Jones used to go into organized places
where it was said that anyone else goes
in they come out in a box that was
literally true by these private guards
abrogating people's civil liberties as
Americans taking away their civil
liberties that's the sort of fight that
she and those who are our followers see
themselves as being end
I love this cartoon we're in Colorado
she's being held by the Czar chases the
general of the militia and the governor
Amin's hey you have to understand this
is this is a woman who is very very rare
irreverent that's why she is the most
dangerous woman in the world in America
because she can stir up men because
instead of calling instead of paying the
respect she's supposed to to the likes
of john d rockefeller when one minister
refers to him as the greatest man in
america she's she first it was oily john
and says well certainly the greatest
murderer there's no doubt about that and
the greatest criminal certainly that she
refers to the governor of West Virginia
William Glass cops she refers to him as
she says crystal Peter so as you know to
avoid embarrassment avoid and crystal
Peter um it's a joke you can laugh
Glasscock crystal Peter free speech may
be in the Constitution but it doesn't go
around here while I'm governor during
the Children's Crusade for example she
said I will tell the president that I
saw men in Madison Square New York City
last night sleeping on the benches and
that the country can have no greatness
while one unfortunate lies out at night
without a bed to sleep on I'll tell him
that the prosperity boasts of his the
prosperity of the rich wrung from the
poor then she talks about Congress I saw
them last winter passed three railroad
bills in one hour and when labor cries
for aid for the little ones they turned
their backs and will not listen I asked
a man in prison once how he happened to
get there he had stolen a pair of shoes
I told him if he had stolen a railroad
he could be a United States Senator and
she goes on further you're told that
every american-born male citizen has a
chance of being president I tell you
that the hungry man without a bed in the
park would sell his chance for a good
square meal and that these little
toilers deformed dwarfed in body and
soul and morality with nothing but toil
before them and no chance for schooling
don't even have the dream that they
might someday have a chance at the
presidential chair this again is part of
part of her technique that sort of that
that hyperbole but at the same time
still making still making very
fundamental and important points
constantly calling attention to the
structure of a
of American class structure and
constantly saying wait a minute that's
not the way it's supposed to be that's
the way that's that's that's that's all
that's her ploy it's one of the best
images we have ever and we don't have a
lot of them actually uh this is oh she's
about just pushing 80 here getting
getting near 80 on the podium many
people commented on her ability as an
organizer Ralph Chaplin who was known as
the wobbly poet described her she might
have been any coal miners wife ablaze
with righteous fury when her brood was
in danger her voice shrilled as she
shook her fist at the coal Operators the
mine guards the union officials she
prayed and cursed and pleaded raising
her clinched and trembling hands asking
heaven to bear witness
the miners loved it laughs cheered
hooted and even cried as she spoke to
them or again Fred Mooney another coal
miner who became a union official she
could permeate a group of strikers with
more fight than could any living human
being she fired them with enthusiasm she
burned them with criticism then cried
with them because of their abuses the
miners loved worshipped and adored her
and well they might because there was no
night too dark no danger too great for
her to face if in her judgment her boys
needed her again this sense of being
being with always being with her her
people and again this cartoon also which
I think this gives a very strong sense
of the reaction a group of desperados
rioting at her and there she is alone
with her umbrella and satchel come on
you hellhounds there was a description
once during when she was organizing in
the minds of an old miner she finished
her speech and there was a bit of
silence people looked at each other as
as the reporter described and silence
and weeping and suddenly one old miner
pushed his way through the crowd a
sniveling it says on his coat-sleeve you
John Walker John Walker was the man who
organized this
the speech you John Walker don't go you
don't go telling us that that there's
Mother Jones that's Jesus Christ come
down on earth again and playing he's an
old woman so he can come here and talk
to us poor devils God God nobody else
knows what the poor suffer that way and
another organizer describing her
I watched the great labor leader Mother
Jones as she walked over the mountains
twelve miles and spoke to the weary
miners for three long hours after she
was true she again trailed back over the
mountains from where she came if the
miners of this state could but picture
the scene as I seen it of that agent
woman mother Jones going and coming over
the mountains they would certainly arise
and be men and not be slaves or cowards
anymore
be men and not be slaves or cowards
that's the contrast that's presented
here now there's all kinds of things we
could talk about with this and I'd
really rather take your questions and
keep keep talking but I do want to say I
think one of the things that's very
interesting from doing the research from
this book is the notion that this woman
in many ways has been forgotten there's
one biography that was written in the
past 20 years ago and and it was not a
it was written in many ways before
people were doing this sort of subject
in many way she's compared to other
labor leaders like John L Lewis sense
that's inappropriate in certain ways
that's not who she is and yet mainly
she's ignored this is a really
fascinating person a great American in
many ways a fascinating American and yet
largely ignored um and I think that's
something worth thinking about and
talking about and wondering why how that
how that happens but I think that's
enough of my talking for now I think I
just soon take questions if yet if you
have some and I guess we could turn that
projector off if that's if someone can
do that appreciate it
yes ma'am well two questions was she
familiar with the Molly Maguires who
were active in the night eighteen seven
the coal miners and then also later in
life did she come to know dorothy day
both good questions um Molly Molly
Maguires it's impossible to know she
must have been familiar with the story
of the Molly's and with what happened in
Pennsylvania and hanging of the Molly
Maguires especially since she came from
Ireland in a County and an area actually
even a parish that was rife with the
Molly Maguires her name for an Irish
organization that was very active in
Ireland before they became the mollies
in America in the mines she must have
known about them it's impossible that
she didn't on the other hand there's no
connection that can be drawn from the
evidence we have Dorothy Day again is a
little later that Mother Jones just a
bit later whether they cross paths or
not I don't know I doubt it I kind of
doubt it yeah yeah yes and she obviously
very very important and another person
who there is a little more written about
but still um not an enormous amount she
was very important Dorothy Day I was
just to make it brief though also
because the Swedish and our temperance
organization ritually was organized as
socialists in the printers in 1850 and
then when you mentioned going out in
Colorado the exciting copper mines
strike JP Morgan on those and socialism
was equated with temperance you know you
keep the steady head there was certainly
connect movement spread over to Sweden
actually have we been formed in America
but the books I have about the Lublin
Oakland iced red they are in Swedish
absolutely and temperance is in many
ways an international movement in
Ireland also before mother Jones even
emigrated to the United States there
were there was father Theobald Matthew
and in Ireland and urging people and
monster hours tens of thousands of
people to take the pledge against
drinking and yes there were connections
strong connections between temperance
and and socialism Mother Jones was a
socialist for some of her life uh uh and
and it did work
the Socialist Party can you talk about
the problems of trying to write about a
legend as much as writing about a person
and how you go about doing the research
to find the real person yeah um
you're basically schizophrenic you're
not sure you're trying to do both
they're there they're interrelated the
legend and the person Mother Jones has
power in many ways comes from her legend
she knows that she helps to create it
she really she really does create it the
creation of Mother Jones in many ways is
what this what the book is about how she
comes to the point comes to the
knowledge that as Mary Harris her maiden
name Mary Jones her married name she's a
poor widowed immigrant working-class
woman poor and dispossessed finally in
America and yet it's what this persona
this this that she creates of of Mother
Jones insisting that she be called
mother and basically creating this
character that's the source of really of
her influence among among American
workers um how you how you go about
doing both in a book is a little bit
difficult I mean it's the book tries to
be both it tries to follow the person
and how that relates to the persona she
creates that's the key part of telling
the story it'll be I don't know if I'm
answering your question out there
yesterday you were saying she's that -
all known and famous perhaps the people
that she was against de Morgan's in the
people that this idea of freedom an
America they have somehow an unwritten
law that you don't want that type of
person to come up to the surface and we
history except for people like you that
disappear that's a great question it's a
really good question and there are a lot
of different ways to answer it um the
winners right history right and and and
in America
the winner is especially in American a
late at the end of the 20th century and
the beginning of 21st or at least the
first few months of the until march of
well actually march of 2000 the winners
were seem to be people of great wealth
and we live and we live in a period
where wealth is continuing to skew even
more than has in the past between the
very wealthy and they're not so wealthy
these things are supposed to be about
your own book but let me urge you to
look at Barbara Ehrenreich Snickle dand
dimed for a reprise of mother Jones's
era a hundred years later um another
another way to think about that I mean
there's the very narrow sense in which I
was told and I don't have this story
I can't affirm this story for sure in
one of the Western mining towns a friend
told me a historian told me that a head
of a Historical Society wanted in one of
these small towns there was a mining
town people there were explicitly asked
were explicitly told not to do anything
in their exhibits on the history of the
IWW of the Western Federation of miners
the two very radical unions that
organized in the West that that is not
going to be a part of our history the
most radical part now that was very
explicit usually I don't think it works
that way I don't think it worked I don't
think history usually works by
censorship I think I think we tend to
want to celebrate winners the winners
tend to write history tend to get to
write the history and certainly tend to
get to promote the history I think
that's one way to think about it that's
a really complicated and good question
but if I had time to think about I'd
probably do a little better okay if John
L Lewis is not a good comparison what
about Emma Goldman and Elizabeth Gurley
Flynn and E and I'd be curious what they
thought of one another because it sounds
like Mother Jones was willing to work
within the confines of capitalism I'm
not sure you could say about the other
two that's again another very good
question Mother Jones is more willing
than they are depending on circumstances
she has very very specific she is a
socialist and her ideas remain really
fundamentally socialist she also knows
she also is very practical take what you
can get what you can and fight again
she's not an anarchist the way Emma
Goldman is she really is not very drawn
to anarchism not particularly drawn to
anarchism there's a wonderful passage in
Leon Trotsky's a diary where he is
reading my Goldman's living my life in
the autobiography of Mother Jones and
comparing them in writing to and then
writing to friends about them he like
Mother Jones and they found her much
more interesting than Emma Goldman
interestingly enough Elizabeth Gurley
Flynn adored Mother Jones absolutely
idolized her found her just just
wonderful that really the mother of
agitators it's a very funny relationship
and a very difficult relationship I
think it's one of the reasons that motor
Johns has not had a lot written about
her is because there are things in her
ideas that are problematic for women who
might write about about her and I think
also I think Mother Jones and these
other women understood that there's a
real problem in American society at the
turn of the last century maybe even
today but certainly at the turn of the
last century that there is room for one
or two very famous women who can be out
there and get the attention but at the
expense of others so that there's really
there are really really strong divisions
between these women that are ideological
that come out of a sense of there's
limited goods out there there's limited
attention span in the press and so on
and so on so there's all kinds of
divisions ideological
career wise and all sorts of things you
know Elizabeth Gurley Flynn had a lot of
personal support from her network of you
know political compatriots you know
Murray Ackley takes her in when she's
thinking you present Mother Jones as the
Barry is very much a loner and so we
despite these ideological differences
where where do you see her sort of
having her personal support network
through all of these years of organizing
that's a good question um and and
Fellini is quite a contrast I mean I
didn't I didn't talk much here speak
speak at all very much about Mother
Jones personally and and she is quite a
loner there are hints at some point that
she's sick and around 1904 and some
fellow socialists do take her in and
nurse her for for a little while and
there's some hints of that sort of thing
when she was in the mining country for
example from the steel country she
mostly stayed she was st. boarding
houses some of the times but she would
also stay in the homes of workers very
often so she had a large very large
network of people she knew but not deep
she seems from what survives of her
letters and her contacts she seems not
to have been terribly close to anyone
her family had been I didn't talk about
this and I really think one of the keys
to understanding her is to understanding
how she becomes Mother Jones is that as
a wife and mother she marries in 1861
and moves to Memphis Tennessee and has
four children a man who's a union a
member of the Union the iron molders
Union moves to Memphis Tennessee becomes
a mother for children and her entire
family her husband and four children are
killed in the yellow fever epidemic in
1867 they all died within a week and she
virtually never accepted one really
important moment virtually never speaks
about this says nothing about it I think
that's very very important for
understanding her it's a silence that
you know finally I had to think about
and write about and do here and I think
it does have to do with I think much of
her life has to do with loss with she
puts it in places with saving
those who who can be saved her own and
her own family who couldn't be saved and
that's not - that's not to take anything
away from her from her ideas from her
what she stood for but I think much of
her energy much of that walking wrath of
God that Upton Sinclair talks about does
come out of her personal background but
she's also after that incident she seems
to be pretty isolated as near as near as
you can tell and that's that is very
hard to tell to integrate that with the
labor work because my understanding is
that those don't always sit together all
that well or sometimes they do but I'm
not clear on this period what their
relationship was or how she could put
those together it's a very good question
and and and she is not first off she's
not an ideologue she's not in some sense
she's not an intellectual she doesn't
write in Darmstadt she's an organizer
and she really sees herself that way and
she's not overly concerned with
ideological consistency in herself or
others she's concerned with building a
broad mass movement and and that
includes industrial organist really
unions industrial organizing the United
Mine Workers is the largest industrial
union in America when she's organizing
she really perhaps more than any other
organizer makes that that creates that
in the late eighth in late 1890s it has
something like 10,000 members a few
years later early in the 20th century it
has 300,000 members after the great
victories in in in the Middle West and
in Pennsylvania she is a socialist
organizes for the Socialist Party
between about 1905 and 1908 and then
breaks breaks with the party although
her ideas remain pretty straightforward
socialist ideas if given her druthers
really up until the end she does believe
in the state
owning basic industries and running and
regulating basic industries and she
advocates that but by the same token she
also immerses herself in individual
strikes that are for particular that are
that are specific to particular
conditions whether it's in steel
coal or garment workers and and she
respects those particular strikes these
are just steps on the way to something
to something much larger that would be
that that was her point of view I don't
know if that answers your question but
she's not this is not an armchair
Socialist finally she leaves the party
because she she finally I don't think
despises is too strong a word the
armchair people in the party and she
just insists on being out there
organizing and that's where people
should be nineteen twelve one of the
biggest biggest years for the Socialist
Party yet in a way it's funny that she
would bail out at a time when it looked
like socialism maybe really could be a
third party yes remarkably nineteen
twelve is the year that Deb's gains a
million votes Eugene Debs and she was
good friend pretty good friends with
Deb's
with Eugene Debs it has to do with some
personal things more than anything else
well when she bails but those personal
things that take place in the party do
create a disaffection not just him the
socialist from all politics that is it's
about at that point that she turns
against publicly anyway against the
suffrage
against women's suffrage around nine to
eleven nineteen twelve because she
simply decides that voting doesn't
really amount to a whole lot that that
finally vote voting in Colorado did not
change anything during the great strike
in Colorado it's one of those
contradictions in her thinking that's
really that's really puzzling and and
very difficult to come to terms with and
to try to figure out but finally she
decides that organizing is about class
classes about unions about workers
creating unions for themselves
organizing themselves
can you say a little bit more about how
she was treated by mainstream media and
what had that changed over time and I
mean you talk about how she um tries to
control over the persona to what degree
she controlled the kind of information
they got to kind of access think that
that's a great question and you yeah I
mean one thing you find is that you
don't you know a person finds that they
don't control the media in many ways the
media controls them and certainly the
image of mother her image of mother
mother the aroused mother defending her
brood sometimes and and though she'll
play with the image of mother as the
long-suffering grandmother often the
image gets translated into just that in
the mainstream media she's just the the
sweet old grandmother kind of thing the
New York Times for example really really
writes very disparagingly of her many
times during during her career during
her during her life and much of the
mainstream media does very dismissively
of her and yet at the same time they do
write about her write about her a great
deal she does get a fair amount of ink
in the various strikes that she's
involved in and actions that she's
involved in um but not always terribly
accurate it's not you can't always the
media certainly is not is not a great
place to find out about her and to tell
her story from you can you have to be
very careful with it do you have any
idea what first sent her off
was there some spectacular happening I
don't know what you mean by well what
when did she first begin to when did you
first get the idea to make to go public
to try to organize that's very hard to
know um
IIIi think I mean I there's there's so
there seems to be so many steps on the
way and no real way to answer when it
really happens she's clearly out there
by the 1890s she's marching with coxey's
army in the West in 94 and and no doubt
she's out there somewhat before them but
I don't think an awful lot before I
think she's preoccupied
until she's 60 years old or so um a
little younger than that with with
earning a living with being she becomes
a dressmaker in Chicago and I think
that's that's a large part of what she
does
even if she's very interested in the
union movement in the left and observing
and paying attention but becoming an
organizer of any sort or really being
involved
I don't think until she's pretty far
along in age and I think partly being
far along an age frees her to do that
that's one of the things that happens
free speech comment in comparison to
Carrie nation I suppose was not all
aligned because most reform movements
even radical ones are initiated by women
one can think of several of these and my
final one was if it was comfortable in
any way to the work of Jane Addams here
in Chicago at first Jane came over and
my father knew her personally as a
immigrant boy but it was to help the
immigrants and the similans the
settlement house even the Sullivan
cookbook but then she had to file that
she had to go into PI I had politics and
take on the polls including the Irish
polls yeah I think one thing that's
that's very important in what you say is
that um and this is a it's a good
example of how interpretations of
history finally catch up in some sense
when I was a student reading about this
period the progressive period as it's
called often uh from roughly the turn of
the century to roughly the first world
war it's told as the story of
legislative reform coming to us coming
down from well obviously all-male state
legislatures city governments federal
Congress and so on and that story's been
retold through the discoveries and
really discoveries I think are is the
right word a really a generation of
mostly women mostly feminist historians
who who have made us start thinking
about the origins of much of progressive
reform
coming from women who found ways to to
develop policies and get them into the
into the political vortex that's putting
it very very simply and I think as
different as Mother Jones is from many
other women as they are from her Jane
Addams and so on they are part of part
of that that process everybody out at
the time that we said that we're going
to end and thank Ellie I think it's
clear that we could go on for hours and
hours with these questions which tells
you something about the thoughts and
excitement that this book stimulates and
as most of you know because of the
number of people that we get at the
newberry doing biographical research
it's very easy to write biography or
relatively easy biography is in some
ways perhaps the easiest kind of history
to write but on the other hand biography
is probably the hardest kind of history
to write well and I think the
accomplishment in this book is that
Elliott has done it well and thank you
very glad that you've done it here thank
you very much